[Music]
this is the black beauty stick insect
a rare bug found only in a tiny 12-acre
area high in the remote mountains of
northern peru
discovered in 2005 the black beauty
stick insect has a velvet black body
covered in small bristles
the only other colors on its body are
its piercing golden yellow eyes and its
bright red wings
not much is known about this species but
scientists have observed it to be most
active at night when its deep black
coloration keeps it hidden from
predators in addition to its powerful
nighttime camouflage the black beauty
stick insect is armed with a gland at
the rear of its head and when threatened
can spray a coercive strong smelling
substance at its attacker
[Music]
because their natural habitat is so
small the black beauty stick insect's
survival is precarious
and because of its striking features
they have become a popular insect in the
pet trade
luckily due to successful captive
breeding efforts this particular threat
may be on the decline
this is the black beauty stick insect
[Music]
you